what we're going to do in this video is
talk about the terms judicial activism
and judicial restraint in many videos we
have talked about how the judicial
branch one of its main powers is to be a
check on the executive and legislative
branch that it can exercise judicial
review over them it can say that a
legislative action that a law that a
statute is unconstitutional it can say
that an executive action say a rule or
regulation or an executive order is
unconstitutional but as it's doing that
as it's exercising its judicial review
how does it go about doing that and this
term judicial activism was first
introduced by arthur schlesinger who
we've talked about in other videos and
it's meant to imply a judiciary that is
not strictly just ruling based on maybe
what the constitution says
but also their own personal ideas so
personal
personal views it sometimes has an
implication that the judges are
overreaching in some way some people
might say it and this would be a little
bit of a negative legislating from the
bran from the bench legislating
legislating
from
the bench and you'll often hear that hey
that judge or that court is legislating
from the bench from the people who don't
like their ruling they're saying hey
they're not strictly looking at the law
they're trying to make their own laws
through their rulings now some would say
that it's it's necessary for the
judicial to do this because they are
interpreting the constitution in the
world as it is and the world that we are
in changes over time
so it is really a form of positive
activism that they are defending
liberties that they are defending rights
especially in the social context that
we're in
i'll leave you to decide whether you
think this is a good idea or not
now judicial restraint is the opposite
of it this is a situation where the
judges or the courts limit their power
so limit
limit their own power
their own
power
where they say hey look our job is to
just be the umpire the referee our job
is not to make new rules and so we are
just going to strictly think about
whether something is constitutional or
whether it is not
and this one of the most seminal cases
on judicial activism versus judicial
restraint happened in the early 1960s
and that is the case of baker versus
carr
and so what happens is that baker is a
resident of shelby county tennessee he
was actually the former mayor of a town
outside of memphis which is in this area
right over here and he says that look
the state is not re-apportioning its
legislative districts the way it should
be that in general every 10 years there
is a census and based on that we have an
understanding of where the population
sits and then the state should be
reapportioning districts based on
population but what baker argued is is
that the state of tennessee actually did
not redistrict since 1901 after the
census of 1900 and it was now the early
1960s
and he says because of that and he
invoked the 14th amendment you weren't
getting equal protection that people in
his county were that had gotten
increasingly urban and had gotten
increasingly dense over the course of
those 60 years that they were getting
the same representation despite having a
larger population than some of the rural
areas where they have a lower population
and had the same number of
representatives
and so he takes this case against the
secretary of state of tennessee at the
time who was carr and it eventually gets
to the supreme court and the essential
question in baker versus carr
is whether the courts even have
jurisdiction over legislative
districting because the districting was
a power of the state legislature in
tennessee and in this case the united
states supreme court actually did vote
in favor of baker so not only did they
say that baker was right in asking for
this redistricting it had huge
implications in saying that yes courts
like the united states supreme court do
have jurisdiction over something that
was officially a legislative duty
telling the legislative that look you've
got to do this because by not doing this
action by exercising your discretion
there you might not be allowing everyone
to have equal protection we have argued
including the two dissenters to the
opinion that this was a form of judicial
activism it increased the power of the
judiciary
and to appreciate the view of the united
states supreme court that they do have
jurisdiction over legislative
districting here is part of associate
justice douglas's concurring opinion
where the performance of a duty is left
to the discretion and good judgment of
an executive officer the judiciary will
not compel the exercise of his
discretion one way or the other for to
do so would be to take over the office
so he's saying look when it is someone's
job where there's an executive officer
to do this duty then the courts should
not have jurisdiction there but then he
goes on to write there is no doubt
that the federal courts have
jurisdiction of controversies concerning
voting rights the civil rights act gives
them authority to redress the
deprivation under color of any state law
of any right privilege or immunity
secured by the constitution of the
united states
or by any act of congress providing for
equal rights of citizens really saying
that look if the court can see that some
right is being violated some right
that's described in any under the state
law under the united states constitution
then the courts do have jurisdiction
the right to vote in both federal and
state elections was protected by the
judiciary long before that right
received the explicit protection it is
now accorded so he's saying look even
before the civil rights act even before
the 14th amendment that this was
something that was part of the charter
of the judiciary part of the federal
court system and so it does lean in
favor of judicial activism because you
can imagine courts and they have cited
baker versus carr since the 1960s
repeatedly as reason saying hey look
we're trying to protect people's rights
and people have a right to do x y or z
even if it hasn't been explicitly
legislated
now there were two dissenters and this
is what the dissenters wrote
the court's authority possessed neither
of the purse nor the sword so here the
purse that's the legislative branch that
can think about budgets or the sword
that's the executive branch the
president's the commander-in-chief
ultimately rests on sustained public
confidence in its moral sanction let me
underline that unsustained
public confidence in its moral sanction
such feeling must be nourished by the
court's complete detachment in fact and
in appearance from political
entanglement and by abstention from
injecting itself into the clash of
political forces in political
settlements so here associate justice
frankfurter in his dissenting opinion is
saying look we should stay out of this
that not only is it not our part to rule
here to say that hey look the
legislative needs to do this
redistricting again he's saying that it
actually undermines the credibility of
the court that the credibility
ultimately rests on sustained public
confidence in its moral sanction and
that by ruling in favor of baker the
court was overstepping these bounds that
people say hey you're trying to
legislate from the bench you're trying
to get involved in the political even
though the court is supposed to stay
above the fray of the political or
another way to think about this is that
associate justice frankfurter subscribed
to the idea of judicial restraint and
felt that the other six justices that
were voting in favor of baker were
practicing to some degree judicial
activism they were getting into the
territory of the other branches of
government